[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle 360 voici les titres
face- à faceace attendu entre les deux
finalistes de la présidentielle Marine
Le Pen et Emmanuel Macron vont débattre
ce soir à la télévision temps fort de
cette campagne de l'entre de tour la
confrontation est inédite peut-elle
encore faire bouger les lignes et
convaincre les abstentionnistes analyse
à suivre et ce débat opposera de visions
de la société deux programmes
économiques irréconciliables l'un basé
sur le protectionnisme économique et la
défense d'une souveraineté nationale
l'autre sur la mondialisation et
l'Europe des thèmes au cœur des discours
des candidats ce soir on en parle avec
mes invités à 19h et à droite l'appel à
voté Emmanuel Macron suscite encore des
remous certains ténor estiment que voter
pour le leader d'en marche revient à
affaiblir la campagne des législatives
elle sera menée par françois Barouin le
détail dans cette édition et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez réagir sur
Twitter avec le hashtag présidentiel à
360 pour m'accompagner ce soir Saveria
RJC en direct de la salle des conférence
du Sénat le multiplex c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite un duel à haut risque cette joutte
cathodique aussi inédite qu'attendue va
pour la première fois mettre prise de
candidats non issu des partis
traditionnels après de multiples
tractations Marine Le Pen et Emmanuel
Macron ont accepté des plans de coupe
les enjeux de ce débat avec Eloise
Grégoire le match de ce soir s'annonce
unique grande nouveauté de ce débat de
l'entre de tour les plans de coupe sont
enfin autorisés ce qui n'était pas
arrivé depuis
1974 enfin ils ont accepté les plans de
coupe avec modération c'est-à-dire que
le réalisateur pourra montrer la
personne qui ne parle pas
comme ça en plan d'écoute ce qui était
interdit depuis 81 depuis Moati et
miteron c'est une règle qu'ils avaient
mis en place à l'époque et qui
permettait au candidat de se concentrer
de relire ses notes de boire un verre
d'eau en 2012 avec la même règle on
aurait pu observer la réaction de
Nicolas Sarkozi lors de ce moment
historique moi président de la
République je ne serais pas le chef de
la majorité je ne recevrai pas les
parlementaires de la majorité à l'Élysée
moi président de la République je ne
traiterai pas mon premier ministre de
collaborateurs cette année une
scénographie très encadrée avec pas
moins de 14 caméras pour couvrir ce face
à face de 2h30 tout a été négocié en
amont le choix des Loges ou encore la
température du plateau à 19° autour de
cette table ovale Marine Le Pen sera
assise à gauche et commencera à parler
et Emmanuel Macron sera lui à droite et
aura le dernier mot à la présentation un
dio inédit exigé par la parité Nathalie
saintc de France 2 et Christophe jacub
bizine de TF1 aucun public sur le
plateau les candidats seront donc seuls
face à des millions de
téléspectateurs Michel zames nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir Michel
alors on a l'habitude de dire que ces
débats sont décisif est-ce que c'est le
cas ce soir en tout cas ils sont très
attendus c'est un peu le grand moment de
la campagne alors c'est vrai que ça fait
43 ans que ça dure cet exercice ils ont
toujours on a toujours dit qu'il était
décisif donc on va attendre ce soir pour
voir s'il est décisif évidemment euh il
y a quand même trois facteurs clés dans
dans ce débat d'abord euh c'est nouveau
il y a un facteur important qui est le
nombre croissant de votants qui se
décide finalement au dernier moment
peut-être même dans les urnes dimanche
prochain aujourd'hui il y a 18 %
d'indécis c'est pas un record c'est un
chiffre important et imaginez simplement
avec ce chiffre qu'on peut assez
révélateur 60 % des électeurs d'Emmanuel
Macron disent aujourd'hui qu'ils vont
voter pour lui mais par défaut alors ça
va être aussi l'un des objectifs ce soir
d'Emmanuel Macron entre autres c'est de
donner une sorte d'envie d'avoir envie
de lutter contre ce vote par défaut
deuxième facteur clé c'est le casting
c'est nouveau là aussi c'est une
première pour les deux candidats ils ne
font pas partie de ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à
présent parce qu'ils n'ont jamais été
forcément en responsabilité en tout cas
à la tête du pays de visions
complètement diamétralement opposé de la
France donc du coup on est dans un
véritable saut dans l'inconnu c'est la
première fois donc c'est pas la première
fois qu'ils vont être sur le même
plateau rappelez-vous il y a eu un débat
à 5 il y a eu un débat à 11 ils se sont
chercher et même très souvent trouvé
ouais alors si on s'arrête un instant
sur les stratégies des deux candidats
euh quelles sont-elles si on commence
par Marine Le Pen voilà alors très
sincèrement ils savent l'un comme
l'autre sur le quoi sur quoi ils vont
être attendus pendant ce débat donc ils
ont travaillé sur cette question euh
notamment sur la posture Marine Le Pen
doit absolument lutter contre cette
posture de l'agressivité de la colère on
sait qu'elle fait peur pour une partie
des français quand on regarde un peu les
sondages donc elle va certainement
prendre le contrepied de cette posture
être un contre-emploi c'est peut-être ce
qu'il peut déséquilibrer d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron dans son équipe on a
visionné les anciens débats et la
posture c'est vraiment la clé ils ont
regardé aussi le débat entre seégolen
Royal et Nicolas Sarkozi vous rappellez
que Nicolas Sarkozi était paru très
calme en opposé donc à seégolen Royal
elle va s'adresser donc aux indécis à
ceux qui ont voté pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ça c'est très clair ce soir
elle a déjà ouvert la porte pour
François Fillon aux électeurs de
François Fillon et à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
très clairement euh elle va expliquer
son programme tenter de rassurer
notamment sur l'Europe sur cette peur
qu'on les Français aussi autour de
l'euro et aller chercher sans ambiguïté
Emmanuel Macron sur les ambiguïtés
d'Emmanuel Macron notamment sur
l'immigration sur ses relations avec la
finance sur ses relations avec l'Europe
et avec Angela Merkel elle va aussi
aller à l'essentiel ce soir les
fondamentaux Macron l'héritier de
François Hollande ça on a beaucoup
entendu le candidat de l'oligarchie vous
rappelez ça aussi c'est quelque chose
qui raisonne comme étant une parole qui
avait largement abondé lors des débats
de la part de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
notamment ça c'est pour la stratégie de
Marine Le Pen qu'en est-il pour celle
qui sera mise en place ce soir par
Emmanuel Macron il y a déjà une première
victoire chez Emmanuel Macron on en
parlait tout à l'heure ce sont ces
fameux plan de coupe alors dans dans
l'entourage d'Emmanuel Macron on crie un
peu victoire sur ce côté-là parce qu'on
va montrer finalement que ça peut
déstabiliser Marine Le Pen sur le plan
attentif montrer ses petits ritus les
petits sourires ça a été une journée
très studieuse pour Emmanuel Macron
visiblement à son QG il a demandé
beaucoup de notes beaucoup réfléchi
notamment sur son programme et pas que
sur le programme également de Marine Le
Pen car le but ce soir d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est de démontrer et de démonter le
programme de Marine Le Pen sur l'Europe
l'euro les mensonges les posture encore
une fois sur le flou et montrer que ce
programme n'est pas applicable démontrer
mais aussi expliquer son propre
programme être didactique clair poser
très important montrer des propositions
des précisions également et surtout
surtout ne pas céder aux attaques être
calme montrer finalement qu'il a déjà
peut-être endossé le costume merci
beaucoup beaucoup Michel pour votre
analyse au lendemain d'un bureau
politique tendu toujours pas d'accord à
droite pour le second tour les
stratégies diversent sur l'attitude
adopter soutenir ou pas Emmanuel Macron
le débat fragilise une droite déjà
affaiblie par la défaite de François
Fillon Fabien
RER tous derrière françois Barouin pour
les législatives officiellement du moins
car si l'objectif est une majorité de
droite en juin prochain pour un
gouvernement de cohabitation l'unité est
de façade chez les républicains au point
que ce matin l'ancien ministre a D
insister pas de coalition avec en marche
tous ceux qui se rapprochent de Le Pen
avant seront exclus tous ceux qui se
rapprochent du Front national pour
législative après j'ajoute que tous ceux
qui se rapprocheront de Macron avant
législative seront exactement dans la
même tarif entre les partisan d'une
droite dure comme Laurent voquier qui
avait refusé toute consigne de vote au
deème tour et d'y respecter le vote
blanc et les jupéistes sensibles au
charme d'Emmanuel Macron la famille LR
apparaît une fois de plus divisé un
bulletin blanc n'a jamais ne sera jamais
président de la République et donc que
ça nous plaise ou non il faudra bien
choisir celui que par conviction nous
préférons voir à la tête de l'État
français pendant 5 ans symbole de ces
discensions pas plus tard qu'hier soir
le Bureau politique échoué de nouveau à
formuler un appel explicite à voter pour
le candidat dans marche au second tour à
la sortie la sénatrice Fabienne Keller
soutient d'Alain Jupé ne cachait pas sa
déception tout le monde n'a pas la même
sensibilité et et ce clivage apparaît
clairement au sein des républiques
comme pour la gauche il y a-t-il
désormais de droites irréconciliables un
projet législatif confié à Eric vert
tentera de les réconcilier afin
d'empêcher l'implosion du parti avant
les législativ et on retrouve tout de
suite Saveria rogec en direct de la
salle des conférence du Sénat pour une
première réaction dans présidentielle
360 vous êtes avec Jean-Baptiste le
mooine sénateur LR qui a rejoint le
staff d'Emmanuel Macron bonjour Jean-M l
alors une réaction alors que françois
Barouin d'exclusion ce qui serait tenté
par une alliance un rapprochement avec
Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il se trompe
lourdement est-ce que vous appelez au
contraire vos anciens collègues des
républicains à vous rejoindre autour
d'un d'un grand bloc progressiste bien
sûr je les appelle à nous rejoindre
parce que on est en train d'écrire une
page de la vie démocratique une page de
l'histoire de France et je veux dire à
françois Barouin qui a été un de ceux
qui a participé à la création de l'UMP
en 2002 avec Jacques Chirac alin Jupé
qu'il faut réfléchir aussi à l'évolution
de ce parti qu'il s'interroge sur le
fait que pourquoi les centristes sont
partis pourquoi les souverainistes sont
partis euh et aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de de progressistes il y a un
moment il va tenir ses réunions dans une
cabine téléphonique monsieur Barouin
donc aujourd'hui les choses sont en
train de se recomposer et et bien toutes
celles et tous ceux qui à droite ont à
cœur les valeurs de liberté euh de
comment dire d'Europe tout simplement
également de de dialogue social de
progressisme et bien ils ont leur place
dans cette grande maison qui est en
train de construire Emmanuel Macron et
je peux vous dire que le vote qui a eu
lieu il y a une semaine est en lui-même
historique que le parti comment dire
héritier du fondateur de la 5e
République ne soit même pas qualifié ça
en diton alors laissons laissons ces
incantations et ces volontés d'exclusion
à ce qu'elles sont il y a bien mieux à
faire construire plutôt qu'exclure c'est
c'est voilà beaucoup plus positif
parlons maintenant du débat de ce soir
jeanm Lemine vous avez échangé cette
nuit avec Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce
qu'il redoute le plus ce soir non mais
Emmanuel Macron il est prêt vous saz il
est prêt pour être président de la
République et donc il est prêt pour
affronter ce soir débattre avec Marine
Le Pen qui est son sa challenger qui est
arrivé 2è derrière lui il y a trois
points d'écart entre eux je le rappelle
donc il est prêt parce que ça fait plus
d'un an qu'il a lancé cette magnifique
aventure et si vous voulez il avait à
l'époque le défi et bien d'enreiller
cette fatalité d'avoir le Front national
en premier parti de France le Front
national n'est pas le premier parti de
France puis que c'est en marche qui
arriv arrivé en tête avec Emmanuel
Macron avec 24 % des voix et donc ce
soir Emmanuel Macron il va s'attacher à
déconstruire toutes les fariboles
etement précisément précisément quels
vont être ses angles d'attaque on sait
qu'il veut visiblement attaquer Marine
Le Pen sur le fond de son programme la
discrédité sur les revirements sur
l'euro mais aussi les affaires
judiciaires décrédibiliser son image
c'est
ça vous savez euh Emmanuel Macron
effectivement il s'attache au fond euh
et donc il veut pas être dans les
incantations il est pas démagogue il est
pédagogue et donc il va bien s'attacher
à montrer aux Français que porter une
voix pour Marine Le Pen et bien c'est
porter un mauvais coup au pouvoir
d'achat ça veut dire que demain
effectivement bien il y aura un
renchérissement d'un certain nombre de
produits de la vie quotidienne des
Français ça veut dire que demain euh et
bien il y aura une hausse des taux
d'intérêt massive et brutal si Madame Le
Pen devait venir à la tête du pays ce
qui ne plaît à Dieu n'arrivera pas et
donc si vous voulez il s'agit de encore
une fois de de pointer un certain nombre
d'incohérence parce que Madame Le Pen
elle surf
sur comment dire des contradictions
énormes d'un côté elle dit au chef
d'entreprise je vais
libérer vos énergies le code du travail
les impôts et puis de l'autre côté elle
promet des dépenses folles faramineuses
dont on ne sait pas comment elle les
finance et donc tout cela prépare des
lendemain qui déchante pour les
électeurs qui par dépit ont envie
d'envoyer tout valdinguer et et de voter
par Mame Le Pen et donc Emmanuel Macron
ce qu'il souhaite c'est
reconquérir ses électeurs qui en ont
assez et Emmanuel Macron porte cette
envie d'alternance de double alternance
avec le quinquena qui s'achève et avec
les 20 dernières années où allez droite
et gauche ont échoué il faut le dire
est-ce que le défi pour Emmanuel Macron
ce soir c'est pas aussi également de
susciter l'engouement l'adhésion et non
la résignation on sait que c'est le cas
de beaucoup d'électeurs de droite qui en
fait se résoudent à se résolvent pardon
à à voter dimanche Emmanuel Macron mais
c'est ce n'est pas un vote d'adhésion
comment on suscite l'engouement deux
choses l'engouement vous savez sur le
terrain je le vois les équipes
d'Emmanuel Macron les équipes d'en
marche elles sont très présentes elles
sont pimpantes elles sont gay elles
donnent envie d'aller conquérir d'avoir
une France voilà conquérante réconciliée
avec elle-même et par ailleurs on
comprend qu'il y a des orphelins de
François Fillon des orphelins de Bono
mon des orphelins de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais on les je les incite à regarder le
projet d'Emmanuel Macron parce que ils
ont tous une bonne raison d'y trouver
des raisons d'espérer que ce soit sur le
égalien que ce soit sur l'école bref il
y a une opportunité formidable pour
relancer notre pays merci merci
Jean-Baptiste LEM merci beaucoup merci
merci ça rien pour cette première
réaction on continue l'analyse de cette
campagne d'entre de Tours avec vous Tam
Tran nuit bonsoir tous les jours vous
passez au crible les propositions des
candidats on va s'intéresser ce soir à
la réforme des retraites proposé par
Emmanuel Macron on l'écoute d'ailleurs
tout de suite je ne modifie pas l'âge de
départ à la retraite durant le quinquena
je ne modifie pas non plus les règles et
pour les retraites
et pour nos concitoyens qui sont à 5 ans
du départ à la retraite mais
progressivement je mets en place un
système beaucoup plus juste et
transparent où chaque euros cotisé donne
lieu au même droit ce qui veut dire que
vous êtes journaliste vous êtes
fonctionnaire vous êtes commerçant
artisan vous êtes agriculteur vous êtes
ouvrier et bien 1 € cotisé donne lieu au
même droit quel est donc ce nouveau
système que propose Emmanuel Macron
alors déjà on va commencer par ce qui ne
change pas dans ce système c'est que ça
reste un système de retraite par
répartition c'est-à-dire que les
salariés continuent de cotiser pour les
retraités actuels pour les pensions des
retraités actuells on n'est pas dans un
système par capitalisation où l'on
cotise pour sa future retraite en
revanche aujourd'hui et bien le régime
il fonctionne par annuité la pension
dépend du salaire de de référence et du
nombre de trimestres cotisés et là et
bien effectivement le candidat d' marche
propose une véritable révolution il
propose une version sophistiquée de la
retraite par point c'est-à-dire que
chaque salarié va accumuler un capital
virtuel en fonction de ces cotisations
qui se trouve sur un compte qui est
augmenté un peu chaque année un peu
comme un compte épargne et à la
liquidation et bien le compte et bien
devient une rente annuelle en quoi
est-ce que c'est plus juste et plus
transparent ce système et bien parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron par ce système on
termine en fait avec les différences
entre le public où la retraite est
calculée à partir du salaire des six
derniers mois le privé ou la retraite et
elle basée sur les 25 meilleures années
ou même les indépendants et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il parle d'un
système universel de retraite où je le
cite 1 € cotisé donne droit au même
droit quel que soi les parcours et les
statuts en tout cas ça ne devrait pas du
tout plaire au salariés du public qui
ont aujourd'hui le système le plus
favorable que va-t-il arriver au régimes
spéciaux de retraite et bien là l'idée
c'est de les faire disparaître
progressivement mais tout de même c'est
le grand flou on ne sait pas à quel
rythme et apparemment il y a même
certains régimes spéciaux de retraite
qui vont continuer à exister
l'économiste Jean Pisani ferry en charge
du programme d'Emmanuel Macron à a été
interrogé sur l'avenir des régimes
spéciaux de retraite de la SNCF ou
encore de la RATP et là il a déclaré
qu'une entreprise publique pourra
surcotiser pour permettre à certains
salariés de partir plusut tôt à la
retraite si c'est nécessaire justement
Emmanuel Macron clame qu'il ne touchera
pas à l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite est-ce qu'il faut le croire oui
il a déclaré effectivement qu'à court
terme ce n'était pas nécessaire étant
donné les dernières réformes qui ont été
faites ce n'est pas urgent et en clair
il laisse ça au prochain gouvernement il
ne touche donc ni à l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite qui reste à 62 ans
ni aux personnes qui partent à la
retraite dans moins de 5 ans euh en
revanche aujourd'hui bien il faut savoir
que l'âge minimum pour une retraite à
topelin est de 67 ans et là cette notion
de retraite à toelin elle risque elle de
disparaître puisque la retraite dépendra
seulement du capital virtuel accumulé
puis du taux de conversion qui sera
appliqué au moment où cela devient une
rente annuelle oui et au niveau du
financement est-ce que l'équilibre est
assuré par cette réforme bien écoutez à
long terme ça marche puisque le montant
versé par une génération est censé être
équivalent au montant perçu par cette
génération une fois qu'elle part à la
retraite reste que l'on reste toujours
sur un système par répartition et donc
avec les mêmes problèmes qu'aujourd'hui
où les cotisations actuelles servent
donc à payer les pensions actuelles et
donc on voit mal comment financer par
exemple un papy boom sinon je précise
tout de même qu'Emmanuel Macron a décidé
que cette réforme elle se ferait de
façon très concertée et qu'elle ne
s'appliquera qu'à la prochaine
législature en résumé Tam bien en résumé
Emmanuel Macron propose une réforme
radicale des retraites qui qui promet la
fin des différences entre le public le
privé et les indépendants mais une
réforme qui reste très floue sur les
régimes spéciaux sur les modalités de la
réforme qui ne règle pas la question du
financement et qui ne s'appliquerait
quoi qu'il arrive qu'en 2022 merci
beaucoup Tam pour ces précisions dans le
match qui oppose Emmanuel Macron et
Marine Le Pen certaines images fortes
ont marqué l'entre de tour ont-elles
réellement le pouvoir de faire pencher
les indécis en faveur de l'un ou de
l'autre avant d'en parler avec mes
invités les explications de Sandra
serkerera un discours jugé décevant une
fête controversée à la Rotonde Emmanuel
Macron critiqué sur son attitude le soir
même du premier tour puis sur sa
discrétion de jours Absen du terrain
trop occupé à consulter en vue d'une
future majorité donnant l'impression
d'enjamber le second
tourur face à une Marine Le Pen
omniprésente dans les médias agressive
en campagne sur un marché dès le
lendemain du premier tour elle entend
bien donner le tempo de la
campagne après un faux départ Emmanuel
Macron se rend à Amien en terfn pour
discuter du cas whpool c'était sans
compter sur sa rivale qui s'invite sur
le parking de l'usine Emmanuel Macron
venait ici et qu'il entendait pas
rencontrer les salariés qu'il entendait
pas venir sur ce piquet de grève mais
qu'il allait dans un à l'abri et bien
j'ai trouvé que c'était une
preuve tellement de mépris à l'égard de
ce que vivent les
salariés elle ne restera que 20 minutes
sur place sans formuler aucune
proposition pour l'avenir du site mais
les images sont là elle enchaîne les
selfies pendant que son adversaire
s'entretient à hos à la Chambre de
commerce avec des représentants de
l'intersyndicale Madame Le Pen est donc
venu à mien parce qu' j'y venait
bienvenue à elle mais Madame Le Pen n'a
pas compris comment fonctionnait le pays
nous n'avons définitivement pas les
mêmes ambitions elle fait elle de
l'utilisation politique puisquelle va
haranguer des militants politiques sur
un
parking c'est 15 soit 2 he après Marine
Le Pen que le candidat d' marche arrive
sur le site et l'accueil est tout sa
chaleureux sen suit un échange de 45
minutes avec les salariés Emmanuel
Macron s'en sort tant bien que
mal le jour suivant nouveau choc des
images et nouveau coups de com à l'aube
Marine Le Pen embarque sur un chalutier
avec des pêcheurs elle se veut la
candidate du peuple qui se lève Tôti
c'est le travail de trer don il parle
c'est le travail de s amis des grandes
banques des grandes puissances
financières on voit bien d'ailleurs il a
le plus grand mal à parler à la France
qui TR
Emmanuel Macron enchaîne lui TR
commémorations en 4 jours le ton est
solennel et l'objectif évident assimiler
le FN à la xénophobie tout en cultivant
une image de Président nous avons
aujourd'hui un devoir qui est double le
devoir de mémoire Le Pen l'héritière ne
la sifflez pas combattez-la Macron le
visage de la finance françois Hollande
veut vous imposer son Poulin les
finalistes se confrontent par meeting
interposé le 1er mai avant le grand
débat où ils se retrouveront pour la
première fois face à
[Musique]
face et mes invités sur ce plateau
Cécile aldui bonsoir vous êtes
chercheuse associé au cvipof à scienp
professeur de littérature à Stanford et
vous êtes l'auteur de ce qu'il disent
vraiment les politiques pris au mot des
éditions Le Seuil merci d'être avec nous
j'accueille également jar courtois
bonsoir éditorialiste au monde auteur de
parti de campagne la saga des élections
présidentielles aux éditions Périn merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation Vincent
Martini est également sur ce plateau
bonsoir maître de conférence à l'École
polytechnique vous êtes chercheur
associé au svipof auteur de dire la
France Culture identité nationale au
presse de Scien Po et puis Jean Garic
bonsoir vous êtes historien professeur à
l'université d'Orléan à Scien poaris
auteur de élsée Circus une histoire
drôle et cruelle des présidents aux
éditions Talandier Cécile aldui on voit
et bien cette campagne qui est marquée
par la bataille des images avec cette
séquence notamment à whpool cela revient
à dire qu'il y a deux visions très
opposées de la société c'est ce qui va
être en jeu ce soir celle de la
souverainiste contre l'Européen de la
candidate du peuple contre le candidat
de l'oligarchie c'est comme ça que
Marine Le Pen justement et bien qualifie
Emmanuel Macron oui c'est comme ça que
elle qualifie Emmanuel Macron
effectivement je crois qu'il y a ce soir
enjeu de définir les termes de cette
opposition chacun va essayer de définir
dans quelle mesure sa décotomie est
celle soit de l'oligarchie contre le
peuple ou bien version Emmanuel Macron
les vrais patriotes c'est lui et les
nationalistes qui seraient le Front
national Jean Garg est-ce que c'est la
première fois que les clivages sont
aussi marqués on le voit sur l'euro les
travailleurs détachés les accords
commerciaux l'immigration tous les
sujets européens bien sûr c'est un
clivage sans précédent qui sépare ces
deux candidats alors que le clivage soit
marqué il l' a souvent été euh les
affrontements droite gauche étaient
souvent des affrontements forts que ce
soit en 74 en
1981 et ensuite entre Jacques Chirac et
et François mitéran les clivages étaient
marqué mais le clivage aujourd'hui il
est nouveau c'est ça tout toute la
question c'est-à-dire qu'on est sorti du
dialogue bipolaire entre la droite et la
gauche classique tel qu'on la
connaissait c'est c'est même le
l'enseignement majeur de ce de ce
scrutin et on passe aujourd'hui dans un
un rapport qui au fond colle beaucoup
plus à la société française
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire d'une
certaine manière ben ceux qui vont vers
ce qui s'accommodent de la
mondialisation qui essaie en tout cas de
l'accommoder avec le socle de l'État
provovidence et j'y insiste parce qu'on
Macron nous propose pas d'aller vers la
société du grand capital il dit c'est
pas une mondialisation heureuse c'est
juste un positionnement juste de la
France et de l'autre côté une candidate
qui se fait le porte-parole d'une France
qui souffre objectivement c'est-à-dire
de de ceux qui sont les les déshérités
les laissés pour compte de la croissance
on retrouve un petit peu un un dialogue
politique qui avait existé dans les
années 50 entre Pierre mandz France
toute proportion gardé hein et de
l'autre côté le le poujadisme Pierre
Poujade qui représentait aussi une
France malheureuse à cette époque et ce
ce clivage là il a toujours existé en
société française mais il est évident
que la crise depuis 2008 et puis l'échec
de l'alternance depuis 2007 euh Nicolas
Sarkozi Franois Hollande bien tout ça
fait exploser ces les les codes et et et
et donne cet affrontement nouveau ouais
Vincent Martinique quel regard vous
portez-vous sur la façon dont ces deux
finalistes ont choisi finalement de
mener cette bataille des idées cette
campagne qui passe aussi par une
bataille des images on l' vu il y a pas
qu'une bataille d'idée moi je dis
d'abord il y a une bataille d'image
d'ailleurs c'est un peu le problème de
cette campagne il y a pas eu beaucoup
d'idées ni avant le premier tour ni même
dans l'entre de tours on se bas sur des
images je crois que les deux ont accepté
justement la dichotomie dont on parlait
tout à l'heure sur entre la France
ouverte et la France fermée ou en tout
cas une France se replier sur la
question de la souveraineté et une autre
qui revendique d'être ouverte et je
crois que là làdedans il y a un piège
politique à long terme à mon avis pour
Emmanuel Macron s'il venait à remporter
cette élection présidentielle si on
accepte une dichotomie parfaite entre
d'un côté ceux qui seraiit les libéraux
les cosmopolites donc incapable
d'enraacinement et de l'autre les
nationalistes ou les patriotes qui eux
auraient sera attaché à un terroir et
donc aussi incapable d'avoir un lien
avec l'extérieur d'avoir une ouverture
vers l'extérieur il peut sortir de ce
piège ce soir par un discours il va
falloir qu'il il soit meilleur que ce
qu'il a été jusqu'à présent en fait la
difficulté c'est que il incarne un peu
jusqu'à la perfection ce système de de
France ouverte parce qu'il veut forcer
le clivage donc ça ça marche encore
entre deux tours mais c'est juste après
que ça va se jouer ouais Genard courtoi
dans votre ouvrage on voit bien qu'il y
a ces neuf campagnes présidentielles qui
ont marqué la vie politique depuis 50
ans cette saga que vous vivez au premier
log notamment depuis 88 on a dit et bien
que cette campagne là était
particulièrement inédite est-ce qu'elle
est réellement au regard des campagnes
précédentes ah oui elle est très inédite
à tous égards alors on va faire
l'inventaire de toutes les surprises
c'est le coup de théâtre permanent
depuis non seulement sur la campagne
mais en plus on a rajouté des primaires
à droite à gauche et chacune des
primaires a été a été l'objet Def a
débouché sur une surprise je juste
garder deux ou trois différences
essentielles qui à mon avis pèsent sur
le le climat et sur la dramaturgie de
cette campagne première différence le
président sortant ne se représente pas
bon voilà c'est la première fois et ça
prive me semble-t-il le débat d'une
espèce de de de socle de réalité
est est
cont on le défend mais voilà il y a ça
déstabilisé tout le système c'est ce que
vous dites ça moi je pense que ça a
donné libre cours à ce que j'appellerai
la pensée magique poliment pour ne pas
dire la démagogie et quand je suis tout
à fait d'accord il n'y a pas eu dans
cette campagne c'est une autre
singularité dans chaque campagne il y a
une proposition majeure qui qui
structure le débat alors ça a été la
finance en 2012 ça a été le pouvoir
d'achat avec Sarkozi en 2007 ça a été la
sécurité en 2002 avec Chirac la fracture
sociale avec Chirac en 2 en 95 c'est pas
la question de l'Union européenne de la
mondialisation aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
une proposition c'est une problématique
qui est posée par les uns ou par les
autres mais par rapport à l'enjeu
ouverture fermeture Europe frontières et
cetera il n'y a pas réellement de de
proposition qui fassent qui soit neuve
et qui fasse sens Madame Le Pen dit on
va sortir de l'euro ou de l'Europe puis
ensuite elle elle elle comment dire elle
biaèise elle essaie de de voilà
d'arrondir les angles et d'éviter que ça
soit un un chiffon rouge mais mais ça
d'abord ça fait 6 ans qu'elle le dit euh
et donc y a il y a aucune proposition n
enfin me semble-til aucune prop de la
part des candidats mais peut-être de la
part des électeurs qui on Candat poussé
au renouvellement ça explique la
frustration qui est très perceptible des
électeurs au fond les électeurs
s'apprêtent à voter pour un candidat
selon les sondages on en sort encore un
aujourd'hui du cvipof avec avec hipsos
c'est la la grande enquête électorale du
cvipov bon Emmanuel Macron paraît assuré
de l'emporter mais assuré de l'emporter
par défaut ce qui est quand même une une
très grande singularité par rapport aux
autres campagnes il devra susciter
l'adhésion notamment ce soir dans ce
débat Cécile al c'est l'enjeu pour lui
alors l'adhésion déjà les votes ce
serait déjà pas mal mais je voudrais
revenir sur ce qui a été dit parce que
c'est vrai que aucune idée phare aucune
mesure nouvelle n'a émergé alors qu'on
avait prédit que cette campagne serait
sur la sécurité et sur l'immigration et
on faut quand même souligner aussi
l'échec de Marie Lepen elle-même a
structurer cette campagne autour de ces
thèmes favoris rien némerge finalement
de cette campagne y compris pour
elle-même alors qu'elle est au second
tour qui est un fait historique et
inversement les électeurs quand on les
interroge et dans la même étude du cvipp
je crois on leur demande quels sont les
enjeux de cette campagne et les deux
principaux enjeux c'est premièrement le
pouvoir d'achat deuxièmement
l'immigration or chacun des candidats a
des mesures
pour l'un ou pour l'autre mais pas les
deux c'estd que la société elle est
clivée sur des demandes différentes
certaines
Emmanuel Macron y répond il a une vision
très économiste de la société et des
problèmes et d'autres l'immigration la
sécurité c'est plutôt mari Le Pen mais
ce sont deux Frances très différentes
qui ont des des priorités diichotomique
finalement Jean vous êtes d'accord avec
cette analyse il y a pas eu de thèmes
qui ont réussi à être imposé par les
candidats dans cette campagne notamment
sur l' deour vous surprendre parce que
j'ai pas tout tout à fait le la même
opinion que je dirais que l'ensemble
d'ailleurs de des observateurs moi je
considère au contraire que que que cette
élection a été depuis les primaires
l'occasion de développer un certain
nombre d'idées qui sont qui transgresse
ce qu' a été jusqu'à présent le le débat
politique euh que ça soit le revenu
universel d'existence lancé par Benoît
amont que ce soit l'écosocialisme
développé par amont et par Mélenchon
dont on r trrouve même des traces chez
euh chez euh euh Emmanuel Macron que ce
soit le la tentative d'Emmanuel Macron
de de constituer ce qui ce que
finalement François berou demandait
depuis 2002 c'est-à-dire un
rassemblement ni à droite et à gauche ou
plutôt et à droite et à gauche que ça
soit d'ailleurs la transgression majeure
de Marine Le Pen sur la sortie de l'euro
il y a eu beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites et et des choses qui sont vraiment
des ruptures par rapport à au traintin
j'allais dire au train-train politique
qu'on a connu de depuis des années en
revanche le problème c'est que cette cet
ensemble de propositions a été
complètement fagocité par un climat de
de sinistrose qui vient notamment de du
penéope gate mais pas seulement de tas
d'autres facteurs et notamment
d'ailleurs je pense du du positionnement
dans cette campagne de de Jean-Luc
Mélanchon et de la France insoumise qui
a contribué beaucoup à disqualifier la
plupart de ces de ces adversaires et et
je pense que malheureusement si vous
voulez cette cette
possibilité d'éclosion ou d'explosion a
été un peu tué dans l'œuf par tout ce
qui s'est passé pendant cette
campagnetin alors je suis d'accord avec
ce que dit Jean gar il y a eu des idées
dans la campagne au premier tour le
problème c'est que ceux qui portaient
ces idées n'ont pas été qualifiés au
deuxème c'est qu'on a le sentiment que
ceux qui étaient les candidats qui
proposaient le plus de choses nouvelles
en l'occurrence Benoît amont jean-
menchon 6e république mettre l'écologie
au centre de la campagne repenser le
travail et ce qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
sur ces sur ces hypothèses ou sur ces
enjeux en fait sont ceux qui n'ont pas
été qualifiés ceux qui sont qualifiés
sont pour Marine Le Pen avec un récit
très clair une façon de dire la France
en l'occurrence là qui est très lisible
mais qui ne renouvelle pas ce qu'elle
disait depuis 6 ans disait Gérard
courtois plus sur certains thèmes sur
l'immigration c'est vraiment la ligne
directe du Front national qu'on connaît
depuis presque les origines du parti ou
plutôt depuis que le parti a émergé en
83 et de l'autre vous avezmanuel Macron
qui a une vision ccileu le rappelait
très économiciste donc dont le récit
culturel est très faible en fait on
comprend pas exactement ce qu'il propose
comme vision de l'histoire de France on
a l'impression qu' suit un certain
nombre d'étapes he la visite au Mémorial
de la Choa est l'une d'entre elles parce
qu'il a le sentiment que voilà il faut
faire ça mais on voit pas exactement ce
que propose Emmanuel Macron à part un
récit très désincarné sur la France
ouverte une idée que bah voilà ce qui
caractérise la France c'est l'ouverture
au monde et c'est l'Europe mais c'est un
récit sur lequel les électeurs se
retrouvent pas tout à fait ça manque un
peu de cher écteurs qui les ont pourant
porter au second tour ces candidats
comment vous expliquez ce décalage
Vincent Martini après il y a des
logiques électorales
h dis
parx dansidou rleès fa c'est à la fois
paradox Paron vient de dire qu'au
premier tour il y a eu des gens qui ont
proposé des choses nouvelles mais ce
sont pas eux qui ont gagné c'est on se
rend compte au svipof on a fait un
projet qui s'appelle la boussole la
boussole des présidentielles pour
essayer de réfléchir au votes sur enjeux
et bien on se rend compte qu'il y avait
une déconnexion entre les enjeux auquel
les gens adhéraient et les hypothèses de
vote qu'il formulaient c'estàd qu'il y a
pas d'adéquation entre donc à priori
cette élection joue pas sur des enjeux
elle se joue sur des imaginaires et donc
il semblerait que pour des raisons
division aussi de l'espace politique à
gauche ça a pas été possible de faire
porter ces nouvelles idées au deuxième
tour c'estard pour oui alors en fait
jeis revenir sur sur l'idée de
qu'immanuel Macron n'a pas une vision
culturelle de la France en fait je pense
qu'on le reprend jamais dans les médias
mais pour avoir étudié un peu ses
discours j'étais très surprise en fait
de regarder et de m'apercevoir que
lui-même parle de la France éternelle
des racines de ces paysages cette langue
française qui est le socle commun dit-il
de notre roman national et je reprends
ces expressions des expressions qu'on
l'habitude d'entendre chez François
Fillon chez Marie Le Pen et pas du tout
à gauche roman nationale France
éternelle donc en fait il faut aussi
voir que il y a un
prisme de du des campagnes négatives qui
sont formulé par les aut advversaires
qui fait que on nécoute pas l'ensemble
des discours jamais et c'est vrai que il
y a un point com enfin une sorte de de
de de de de colonne vertébrale des
discours d'Emmanuel Macron surtout qui
est de donner à chacun sa place dans la
société et c'est vrai pour l'histoire
donner à chacun une place dans
l'histoire de France ce qui est une
nouveauté d'avoir de un sorte de r
national qui embrasse toutes les
histoires et c'est vrai pour la société
pour l'économie et cetera pour
l'éducation donc c'estàdire que au lieu
d'avoir une idée for qui serait une
mesure le revenu universel il a un
concept donné à chacun sa place dans la
société et peut-être qu'il a pas la
formule un peu plus synthétique qui
permettrait d'en faire une thématique
porteuse synthétique ou ou pratique ou
prtique a ça n'imprime pas c'est quand
même ça le le très commun au fond à tous
les candidat vous je reviens sur un mot
vous disiez vous disiez les ceux qui
étaient porteurs d'idées par exemple
Mélenchon amont ou Fillon ont été battus
rappelons quand même que ça s'est joué à
très peu de chose c'est une autre
singularité de cette campagne c'est
c'est je dire dans toutes les campagnes
précédentes au mois d'avril au début du
mois d'avril on savait qui étaient les
deux finalistes il y avait pas photos
même en 2007 où à un moment Baayou s'env
et puis et puis il retombe en 2012
François Hollande a été en tête pendant
toute la campagne absolument et et là on
se retrouve dans cette situation
extraordinairement nouvelle d'avoir
quatre candidats qui sont autour de 20 %
bon alors qui se départagent à un point
près hein ce qui est vraiment peu de
choses et qui contrairement à toutes les
les élections précédentes récuse toute
alliance avec n'importe lequel des
autres ce qui fait qu'on se retrouve
devant une sorte de d'inconnu sur la
suite qui est assez sa ante jean-garry
oui je voudrais revenir sur ce que
disait Cécile aldui avec je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce qu'elle
disait tout à l'heure euh c'est toujours
difficile de dire du mal de du du bien
pardon du mal c'est facile mais dire du
bien d'Emmanuel Macron parce qu'on est
tout de suite accusé d'être un
macronisme bélan mais je crois
queobjectivement Emmanuel Macron en tout
cas était victime de cette
disqualification dont je parlais tout à
l'heure de certaines caricature autour
de sa de de de de ce qui'est sa propre
image caricature qu'il a peut-être
lui-même d'ailleurs euh favorisé en
quelque sorte mais si l'on s'intéresse
précisément à ces discours il se trouve
que j'ai eu aussi l'occasion de
travailler sur sur son discours on
s'aperçoit que c'est un discours qui a
une colonne vertébrale qui est structuré
sur une vision de la France sur des
moments décisifs des moments de
tournants euh parmi lesquels il cite
d'ailleurs il inventorie deux majeurs
qui sont celui de la Libération général
de GA et toute une génération transforme
la société française et crée l'État
providence et puis un deuxème tournant
et ça ça c'est c'est plus original qui
est celui de ma 68 qui lui apparaît
comme un tournant culturel le courant
d'une émancipation libertaire enfin des
des des notions de base de notre société
d'aujourd'hui finalement et ça c'est
très intéressant parce que ça montre
qu'il s'inscrit dans une perspective de
rupture d'abord avec ce qui est et une
perspective de rupture qui s'appuie sur
un socle culturel précisément sur une
vision de ce que peut être le le je veux
dire l'émancipation de la société
française et son émancipation alors
c'est vrai on peut la rechercher du côté
d'origine sociale libérale
social-démocratique elle s'inscrit dans
dans des codes politiques qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui mais néanmoins elle elle
s'inscrit dans une véritable
problématique d'émancipation et je le
répète avec une architecture
structurelle derrière Vincent Martini je
trouve c'est un peu optimiste en fait
moi je trouve que quand même euh c'est
c'est un récit je dis qui est pas faible
mais qui est brouillé euh c'est c lui a
raison il parle de la France éternelle
hein il a toujours un discours très fort
là-dessus même à le début on on l'avait
beaucoup raillé sur son discours sur
Jean d' on souvient quasiment avant même
qu'il déclare sa candidature et puis
dans le même tempsou voil exactement en
mai 2016 et en même temps tout sa
déclaration sur n'y a pas de culture
française qui était très importante pour
lui parce que elle a été repris
d'ailleurs juste titre par le Front
National qui a compris qu'il y avait un
cheval de bataille ce qu'il voulait dire
c'est c'est le mélange de de plusieurs
cultures qui créent la culture française
il y a pas une culture française de tout
temps donc là encore une fois c'est un
réci brouillé s'il y a une France
éternelle et qui a pas de culture
française c'est quand même compliqué de
le dire lui ce qu'il veut c'est réunir
tous ces récits sauf que la campagne
présidentielle c'est une campagne qui
est censée donner une ligne et que si on
VO on rege la prime au réit Marine Le
Pen un récit beaucoup plus clair et
surtout un récit beaucoup plus stable
d'une certaine manière Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avait un r très clair lui
c'est référence à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est 1789 1848 1871 1936 1981 bon ces
dates on les connaît elles sont connu à
gauche puisque ce sont les dates
typiques celles de François mitteran
déjà en 1981 chez Emmanuel Macron il y a
la Libération oui comme Nicolas
sarcooszi puis m 68 il prend le
contrepied pour montrer un coup à gauche
un coup à droite en disant finalement m
68 c'est aussi l'air de l'individu c'est
aussi aussi le moment où de
l'émancipation individuelle qui est on
va dire un une dimension très importante
du discours libéral donc à ce titre là
bah c'est quand même pas d'une grande
originalité et en plus on peut pas dire
pour autant que c'est totalement sans
ambiguïté par rapport à Cees discours de
départ sur le sur la France éternelle
alors Jean Garry ens est-ce que ce n'est
pas d'une grande originalité justement
que d'essayer de bousculer cette bip
partition cette bipolarité qui est pas
simplement une bipolarité euh politique
partisane mais que aussi une bipolarité
culturel moi j'ai l'impression qu'au
contraire ça c'est véritablement quelque
chose de très alors évidemment c'est
très difficile c'est ça c'est sujet à à
toutes les je dirais les railleries
d'abord et puis et puis on peut
évidemment se dire que c'est au fond de
la traape tout que ça ça n'a pas de
colonne vertébrale mais en même temps je
trouve que l'idée est quand même très
très intéressante dans un moment où on
constate que notre écosystème politique
est complètement à la ramasse qu'on est
véritablement là en bout de en bout de
cyle je parle pas simplement des
institutions mais l'écosystème politique
français les partis sont rejetés les
acteurs politiques les assemblées tout
est rejeté par par les Français c'est ça
me paraît donc intéressant d'aller
rechercher quelque chose d'autre dans
une construction politique différente et
en essayant d'amalgamer peut-être des
cultures politiques différentes genre
cour toi le récit est une chose et je je
suis d'accord il y a un récit d'Emmanuel
Macron il y a un récit également très
très structuré et et et assez fort de de
Marine Le Pen euh alors pour le meilleur
et pour le pire une élection
présidentielle c'est aussi une machine
pas seulement à raconter une histoire
mais à faire rêver et je dis bien pour
le meilleur et pour le pire parce qu'en
général le rêve est suivi de réveil
douloureux et on l'a vu à peu près à
chaque fois mais les Français ils
n'attendent pas seulement un récit ils
attendent une projection dans l'avenir
et c'est quand même largement ça qui a
fait défaut depuis le début de cette
campagne c'est Luis qu'on qu'on revienne
aussi un instant sur un des temps forts
selon moi de cette campagne c'est le
ralliment aussi de Nicolas dupontignan à
Marine Le Pen comment et bien jugez-vous
ce cût politique pour Marine Le Pen
est-ce que ça a permis aussi de
banaliser le discours du Front national
ce raliment syoliquement je pense que ça
symboliquement c'est très important
qu'un qu'un qu'un leader d'un même petit
parti mais classé traditionnellement
dans la dans la droite classique ser r
li officiellement pour un accord de
gouvernement ce qui est très fort alors
que le Fond national n'a jamais été
capable ni n'a vraiment voulu conclure
de d'alliance avec d'autres partis ça ça
banalise ce parti en même temps j'ai
envie de dire ça le ringardise parce que
on est au moment où tout ce qui est
parti politique est discrédité et éjecté
du circuit et juste à ce moment-là on
fait des des sorte de d'accord de
derrière les portes pour donner un poste
de gouvernement en échange d'un soutien
et cetera donc la du point de vue de
l'image d'un côté ça banalise et ça
normalise de l'autre ça ringardise il me
semble vous êtes d'accord Vincent
Martini je sais pas si ça ringardise en
même temps c'est une tentative normale
d' certaine manière quand vous êtes pas
en tête c'est ce qui était arrivé à
Segolen royale en 2007 rappelez-vous
hein sur les chaînes elle avait essayé
de faire un débat avec François beou
pour espérer le ralliment de François
beayou ça n'avait pas marché à l'époque
bon c'est une tentative de recréer une
dynamique sachant que quand même une des
leçons du premier tour c'est que la
dynamique qu'on avait prêté à Marine Le
Pen n'est pas a été confirmé dans les
urnes ça ça était une difficulté pour
elle parce que on la pensait certains
mêmes institut disaient 27 28 on la
sous-estime et finalement elle est
deuxème avec un score qui est finalement
assez faible qui est le produit aussi
d'une mauvaise campagne globalement elle
a fait une mauvaise campagne de la vie
générale des observateurs c'est dire de
premers tours de premers tours de
premier tour oui je
parlais et d'ailleurs on voit bien que
là elle essaie de de réamorcer la pompe
d'une certaine manière entre les deux
tours elle y arrive d'ailleurs bien
mieux que ce qu'elle avait fait au
premier tour elle s'est un peu réveillé
je crois aussi que elle avait tenté
avant le premier tour de faire plutôt
des petits meetings dans des dans des
campagne elle espérait faire retourner
les les les les campag elle va continuer
parce qu'elle elle terminera sa sa sa
campagne dans la Somme dans enfin elle a
compris quand même il fallait monter un
peu la la pression d'une certaine
manière et on voit bien que justement la
stratégie qu'elle a avec du poignant
fait partie de ça après il est trop tôt
de savoir qu'est-ce que ça va faire
comme comme résultat d' C manière je gar
oui oui alors c'est vrai que on le
disait tout à l'heure la force de Marine
Le Pen c'est sa cohérence par rapport à
son projet de repli identitaire et par
rapport à l'Europe et cetera il y a une
il a une cohérence et c'est vrai que
l'alliance avec Nicolas dupoignan elle
fait un peu sauter cette image de de de
de cohérence puisque elle elle entre
dans une une alliance avec quelqu'un qui
ne partage pas totalement les mêmes
idées par exemple sur la retraite à 60
ans bon il y a des choses très
différentes et on a bien vu de quelle
manière ça faisait exploser le le
programme de de Marine Le Pen puisque
par notamment sur la sortie de l'euro ça
a complètement changé le paradigme de sa
de son programme et que au fond le
financement de son de son programme qui
reposait précisément sur cette idée de
la de la sortie de l'euro lui aussi est
disqualifié par cette alliance mais
c'est vrai aussi comme le disait Vincent
c'est que cette alliance elle était
nécessaire dans la perspective en tout
cas c'est c'est une bonne opération
électorale en vue d'un d'un second tour
potentiellement une bonne une bonne
opération maintenant c'est vrai que par
rapport je le répète à cette idée de de
cohérence là évidemment on peut se poser
les questions alors oui moi il me semble
que c'est c'est vraiment un double
tranchant cette alliance parce que de
toute façon les électeurs de duponignan
qui voulaient aller voter Marine Le Pen
au deième tour l'auraiit fait quelle que
soit la position ou l'accord d'appareil
avec debout la France mais inversement
maintenant la la profession de foan de
Marine Le Pen pour le 2ème tour n'a plus
grand chose à voir avec son ses
engagements de premier or effectivement
la grande force de Mar le pan du frond
national c'est sa constance le caractère
très répétitif de ces mesures et d'avoir
des mesures
identifiables et très clair sortie de
l'euro préférence nationale or là
maintenant sortie de l'euro c'est une
confusion totale Mario maréichal Le Pen
dit une chose Philippe une autre Marine
Le Pen une troisième euh or s'il y avait
bien quelqu quelque chose qui était son
atout c'était la clarté de son message
peut-être un peu plus de détails ce soir
en attendant et bien il y a ce débat
télévisé ce soir et écoutez les conseils
d'un certain François Hollande qui
réagissait tout à l'heure je pense qu'un
débat c'est fonction des circonstances
on ne reproduit pas le débat en 2017 qui
a eu lieu en en 2012 ou ou en 2007 ça
dépend de des protagonistes ça dépend
des situations un débat qui est très
particulier puisque c'est le premier
débat entre un candidat qui représente
l'ensemble de la République et une
candidate d'extrême droite en 2002 il
n'y avait pas eu de débat ce que
j'attends du débat c'est que on montre
que c'est pas simplement deux
personnalités deux projets mais deux
conceptions de la France de l'Europe et
du monde c'est ça qui doit apparaître
aux yeux des Français pour qu'ils
fassent leur choix et je pense que ce
choix doit aller vers ce que l'idée que
nous avons tous de la France courtoi ça
a été rappelé par François Holland à
l'instant c'est vrai qu'en 2002 et bien
Jean-Marie Le Pen n'avait pas participé
au débat JAC shirac n'avait pas voulu
débattre oui voilà face à Jean-Marie Le
Pen c'est pour ça aussi que ce duel
reste particulièrement originale c'est
la première fois qu'un une candidate
d'extrême droite va pouvoir accéder à
dém oui c'est une des innombrables
particularités on va pas en faire toute
la liste mais mais moi ce qui ce que je
trouve très intéressant dans dans dans
ce que dit Hollande là c'est au fond et
il quand on en a parlé qui m'a refait un
peu le le récit de ce débat de de 2012
avec la fameuse anapore et et d'autes
moi
président ce qu'il m'expliquer c'est
que ce qu'il fallait réussir dans un tel
débat surtout quand on était le
challenger contre un président sortant
là c'est une situation un peu différente
c'est d'apparaître comme le futur
président de de de montrer aux Français
par ses mots mais aussi par son allure
par sa sa façon d'être sa façon de
s'imposer
devant l'autre qu'on est le futur
président et Patrick Buisson le le
sulfureux conseiller de de Nicolas
Sarkozi raconte enfin conclut au fond et
et et définit très bien le ce qui s'est
passé dans l'anaphore moi président
martelé par François Hollande devant
Nicolas Sarkozy muet il a parlé d'un
découronnement symbolique et je trouve
ça extrêmement juste le le le roi est là
le roi en exercice le président en
exercice est là et au fond il y a un
passage de relais à vue devant les
téléspectateurs devant les Français et
et la couronne change de tête ouais
est-ce que un des deux candidats jean-
garig a déjà peut-être une longueur
d'avance sur cet aspect et bien de
présidentialité justement ça c'est c'est
pas sûr mais je crois que Gérard CTO a
tout à fait raison les C ces duels de de
second tour ne font pas gagner une
élection mais ils font gagner une
présidentialité ça c'est sûr c'est
toujours celui qui a pris l'avantage
sur ce ce ce point de la présidentialité
pour des raisons différentes Giscard
destin l'avait joué dans la
l'humanisation de son de son image de
technocrate un peu froid et il avait
joué vous n'avez pas le monopole du cœur
ça lui avait permis de de prendre le
l'ascendant dans ce débat et de 7 ans
plus tard à contrario François mitteran
en rappelant que il était le président
du passif avait lui aussi pris pris
l'ascendant et ainsi de suite donc c'est
c'est quelque chose qui qui est très
important et là on se demande en
l'occurrence avec les les deux candidats
qui sont en face de nous on sait qu'on a
quelqu'un qui une sorte de de bloc un
peu un peu monoliique qui est qui est
Marine Le Pen dont on voit assez bien
les les contours et puis quelqu'un qu'on
connaît moins dont on voit bien moins
justement la l'aptitude à la
présidentialité qui est Emmanuel Macron
il y a donc me semble-t-il pour lui un
véritable défi de ce côté-là ouais
Emmanuel Macron on sera le plus
fragilisé ce soir selon vous forcément
le plus fragilisé mais c'est celui qui a
le plus à perdre et aussi le plus à
gagner moi même MACR me rappelle
exactement la position de François
Holland en 2012 où les gens disent à
l'époque il va se faire manger par
Nicolas Sarkozy vous allez voir il sera
incapable de résister ce qu'on a vu
c'est un François hand au contraire très
pugnas qui avait vraiment renversé la
vapeur et qui avait rassuré ses
partisans qui craignaient qu'il ne soit
pas capable de faire face à quelqu'un
dont on disait que c'est une machine de
combat rhtorique qui était Nicolas
Sarkozi là on est exactement dans la
même situation où il y a une crainte des
partisans d'Emmanuel Macron queu Macron
soit un petit peu mise en difficulté
très largement par Marine Le Pen et il
peut tout à fait surprendre il peut et
je crois il a dû beaucoup travailler
j'imagine en tout cas pour tenir le choc
face à à Marine Le Pen et s'il arrive à
découronner symboliquement elle n'a pas
de couronne donc c'est la différence
avec 2012 mais si il arrive à
s'autocouronner d'une certaine manière à
ce titre là ça aura une vraie à mon avis
un vrai impact pas seulement sur le
résultat parce que Jean a raison de le
rappeler il faut rappeler aux
téléspectateurs que jamais dans les
intentions de vote les débat entre deux
tours n'ont eu d'incidence tout à fait
particulière sur le vote peut-être ça se
joue sur un point mais là on est sur des
écarts qui sont tels que ça n'inversera
pas é mais par contre ça peut avoir un
impact très fort sur les débuts du de la
nouvelle présidence que ce soit celle de
Marine Le Pen ou celle d'Emmanuel Macron
ouais c'estéil lu c'est vrai que ça été
rappelé sera intense mais sans
conséquence sur l' finale ou
certainement l'autre chose qui est
paradoxale c'est que on attend ces
débats de présidentialiser celui qui
l'emportera mais en même temps on est
dans dans un cycle électoral qui demande
le renouveau et le changement et c'est
ça toute l'ambiguïté de cette campagne
c'est que d'un côté les candidats les
deux essaient de rassembler de se mettre
dans cette posture du chefs d'État et
donc de se réinsérer dans des codes
alors qu'ils ont gagné en transgressant
ces codes pour une part et donc là c'est
un peu une difficulté ils ont construit
leur image en transgressant les codes et
il faut réintégrer l'habit et le porter
alors que ils n'ont pas construit leur
campagne pour ça ouais il y a aussi ce
poids du vote utile he qui a qui n'a
peut-être jamais été aussi important
Emmanuel Macron disait il va devoir
susciter l'adhésion on sait qu'il y a un
fort taux d'absentionniste qui est
attendu dimanche prochain il y a un un
tau d' absenstionnisme et et et même
parmi ceux qui sont déterminés à aller
voter et y compris à voter pour lui il y
a un une majorité de gens qui disent je
n'y vais pas par adhésion mais par
défaut parce que voilà c'est la seule
solution qui qui qui me paraît
raisonnable ou réaliste dans le contenu
de son adversaire donc ça fait ça n'est
pas un vote enthousiaste il y a il a un
socle d'électorat enthousiaste qui l'a
suivi qui l'a accompagné les marcheurs
il y a toute cette aventure qui est
absolument dans les l' hisoire politique
française extravagante surgissement en
un an d'un mouvement d'un candidat et et
d'un candidat qualifié pour le second
tour et potentiellement président de la
République dans quelques jours donc ça
c'est tout à fait
inoui carrière politique française hein
il faut il faut il faut baver il faut
vraiment rencontrer des échecs s'en
sortir remonterf voilà miteran pendant
20 ans trois fois candidat Chirac pareil
et là on est bon donc il y a cette
espèce de de novation absolue mais cette
novation au-delà du du cercle de de de
de ces supporteurs les plus les plus
déterminés elle n'a pas suscité
véritablement d'engoument plus larg donc
il y a il y a une vraie hésitation des
Français à par rapport au au candidats
avec cet impact attendu sur le début du
quinquenage jean gar ça sera aussi ce so
il y a un défi très important qui qui
qui s'ouvre au au au favoris de cette
élection qui qui Emmanuel Macron ce que
disent les les sondages bon pour
l'instant c'est ce que disent les
sondages mais son défi c'est précisément
de de séduire enfin ce qu'on disait à
l'époque intégrer les masses les masses
populaires le peuple souffrant les
couches les plus déshérité de la société
française n'adhèrent pas au macronisme
et elles sont du côté de Marine Le Pen
soit du côté de de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
donc là il y a un défi énorme et ce défi
d'ailleurs commence ce soir par jusqu'à
présent il na pas infléchi son discours
justement
mis son image parce que il aurait pu
avoir essayer de jouer un peu plus
l'humilité il a essay worldpol c'était
un peu sa sa séquence à la fois
empathique après la séquence rotonde qui
avait voilà qui avait un peu FO dit
beaucoup de gens mais ce qui est aussi
ça va dans le même sens que ce qui vient
d'être dit Emmanuel Macron c'est une
inconnue parce qu'il na pas d'identité
politique il n pas de capital politique
c'est un quelqu'un qui a surgi or
effectivement tous les hommes politiques
se forge une identité au fil des ans des
batailles qui structurent le sens de
leur personnalité pour le publicque or
Emmanuel Macron il est évanescant pour
tout le monde c'est fan l'adule mais
c'est un point d'interrogation c'est un
mystère d'ailleurs moi ce qui m'a
vraiment marqué dans cette campagne
c'est que Macron avant d'être un
candidat c'était un mot c'était un signe
qui venait tout le temps dans les
discussion des autres des commentateurs
même s'il n'avait rien fait et
maintenant il se trouve que il est le
favori et donc il est peut-être même
demain président or personne ne sait
vraiment qui il est euh céit c'est
vraimentun énigme il y a quand même une
dimension assez frappante de cette
élection aussi c'est Gérard côtoi disait
tout à l'heure que dans chaque élection
il faut un peu de rêve les spécialistes
de la démocratie disent en général il y
a un cycle en démocratie illusion
déception hein il faut une illusion et
puis le lendemain on est déçu là on est
dans un cycle où il y a même plus
d'illusion c'estàd que les gens
s'apprêtent déjà àêtre déçu ce qui va
avoir un impact sur ce qu'on appelle
l'état de graince qui avait déjà été
très très limité pour François Hollande
et on peut imaginer qu'il va durer 24
heures
h immé parce que comme
disait deserès restreintor il pas
l'adhésion que aussi Gard courtoi su pas
l'adhésion du grand public et je crois
qu'un des enjeux du débat de ce soir ça
va être pour Emmanuel Macron sa capacité
quand même un peu à incarner un idéal
qui va au-delà de lui-même et qui va
au-delà même des de mots clés qui sont
un peu des motalises auquels on est
habitué aussi depuis Jacques Chirac ces
mots qui tournent un peu à vie de
République de démocratie de liberté et
Cera et ce il a totalement loupé le
coche le soir du premier tour euh en ne
trouvant pas les mots qui qui le mettent
à la hauteur de l'enjeu il en a fait une
affaire personnelle quasi familiale
presque et et là il est vraiment passé à
côté de de de l'enjeu
et juste citation de François mitteran
le soir du premier tour de
1981 contre Giscard destin sa
déclaration est très simple le combat
continue que personne ne relâche son
effort Emmanuel Macron aurait dit ça le
23 avril au soir tout le monde aurait
dit waouh bravo alors que jean-garque
Marine Le Pen a plutôt réussi sa
campagne d'entre de Tours c'est ce que
vous dites oui c'est c'est sûr
qu'elle apparemment ça a mieux
fonctionné pour elle parce que elle a
été dans je le répète dans une sorte de
de de cohérence et puis qu'elle a réussi
ce rapte de sur le sur le du ponignan et
et debout la France maintenant au fond
le le véritable enjeu il n'est pas là
parce que on sait déjà ce qu'elle
représente Marine Le Pen le véritable
enjeu il porte sur sur Emmanuel Macron
et sur ce qu'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
peut peut offrir peut apporter dans la
perspective non seulement de des
élections législatives quelle majorité
autour de lui et puis surtout cet enjeu
majeur je le répète j'y reviens qui est
de d'aller vers vers les les catégories
qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans cette
mondialisation heureuse et ça c'est son
c'est son Paris c'est très important il
suffira pas du récit parce que ce qui
est très intéressant aussi avec Emmanuel
Macron c'est cette idée assumer assumer
la complexité des choses je pense que
intellectuellement c'est une idée très
intéressante mais c'est pas forcément
une idée qui va mot c'est un peu la
problématique aussi de de Marine Le Pen
dans ce débat parce qu'on a parlé
beaucoup de ce que Emmanuel Macron peut
gagner Marine Le Pen elle ne surprendra
pas c'est-à-dire qu'elle peut apparaître
je veux dire très convaincante elle peut
être un bulldoer comme on la connaît
elle peut être même essayer d'écraser
Emmanuel Macron mais par contre c'est
difficile pour elle d'apporter des idées
totalement nouvelles les gens ont image
très fixe de marine LEP donc ceux qui
sont déjà convaincus resteront
convaincus peut-être qu'elle peut
grapiller des voix en plus mais il sera
très difficile pour elle de surprendre
donc d'une certaine manière la position
d' Macron c'est là où il a le plus à
perdre mais c'est aussi là où il a le
plus à gagner et donc à ce titre là ça
ouvre un débat qui va être pour ça
passionnant en tout cas et bien merci
merci à tous les quatre d'être venu en
parler le débat sera d'ailleurs à suivre
sur les chaînes parlementaires à partir
de 19h on continue d'analyser cette
campagne et on voit les répercussions à
présent sur la droite les républiain au
lendemain d'un bureau politique écoutez
la réaction du sénateur philippe
Dominati qui était tout à l'heure au
micro de SAV c bonjour philippe Dominati
bonjour alors depuis hier les
républicains ont un leader pour mener la
bataille des législatives he c'est bien
évidemment françois Barouin mais avec
quel programme vont-ils mener cette
bataille est-ce que c'est celui de
François Fillon non il sera légèrement
modifié d'après ce que j'ai compris
d'abord c'est un bon leader c'est un
homme qui peut établir le consensus dans
notre famille politique et deuxièmement
répondre à des sujets contemporains qui
préoccupent tous les Français le
programme va être légèrement modifié
d'après ce que j'ai compris pour tenir
compte de quelques observations
notamment dans le domaine économique
c'est-à-dire euh c'est-à-dire euh pour
l'atténuer un peu pour le rendre plus
compatible adouci assoup ce programme
c'est ça oui moi je reconnais
personnellement le programme de François
filon me convenait parce que je pense
que nous devons prendre des mesures plus
radical sur le plan de l'économie aller
plus vite être plus réformateur mais euh
nous nous devons tenir compte de la
réalité du terrain pour l'instant nous
ne sommes pas je dirais en mesure
d'imposer un programme aussi austère
est-ce que vous savez précisément sur
quel point précisément sur quel point il
va être assoupli ce programme oh je
crois qu'il va répondre à certaines
demande qui ont semblait trop difficile
à mettre en œuvre il fallait une
présidence forte ce n'est pas le cas
philippe Dominati françois Barouin a dit
ce matin que tous ceux qui se
rapprocheraient d'Emmanuel Macron ser
exclus des républicains est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cette posture bah
pour l'instant oui
puisque le programme de françois Barouin
c'est de faire de proposer un projet qui
est une alternance à la politique du
gouvernement sortant donc vous ne seriez
pas prêt à travailler avec Emmanuel
Macron au sein d'une d'un grand bloc
progressif au sein d'une majorité
élargie Christian estrzi hein ce matin
encore déclaré que c'était une question
de responsabilité de pas laisser la
France en panne pendant 5 ans quelle est
votre position là-dessus non non mais
c'est ça dépend de quoi on parle on
connaît pas encore le le le projet
gouvernemental du prochain Président de
la République on ne connaît pas ni le
Premier ministre ni les personnes
chargées de le mettre en œuvre on ne
sait pas si on peut avoir confiance ou
pas confiance nous nous avons confiance
dans notre projet parce qu'on y a
travaillé pendant longtemps c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu je dirais un
dysfonctionnement dans la campagne pour
autant le projet on le connaît tous le
nôtre et donc on a envie de pouvoir
l'appliquer et pour l'appliquer on va
essayer de convaincre les les Français
de nous faire confiance dans l'élection
législative et après les législatives on
verra mais en tout cas pour l'instant il
est pas question de cohabiter avec qui
que ce soit il est question de mettre en
œuvre notre projet si au lendemain des
législatives ou même avant cela des pois
lourds de votre majorité comme Xavier
Bertrand ou encore Christian Estrosi
quitte les républicains ou en tout cas
pour se rapprocher dans une future
majorité présidentielle pour se
rapprocher d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
ça ça ne fait pas exploser le parti
qu'est-ce qu'il reste des républicains
si ces poids lourds là quittent le parti
vous savez moi je suis pas un homme de
parti je me tiens assez loin de
l'appareil l'appareil a montré ses
déficiences elles ont été nombreuses ces
derniers temps ce n'est pas que la
responsabilité ou l'échec d'un homme les
présidentiel c'est l'échec d'une
formation politique qui a pas su se
moderniser pendant les au cours des
dernières années où on a laissé
prospérer un certain nombre d'écuries
donc l'anathè je crois que il est dès le
lendemain oublié ça a pas de sens
aujourd'hui il faut songer plutôt à la
reconstruction de ce parti de mon parti
politique un mot pour finir très
rapidement sur le débat de ce soir
est-ce que vous attendez d'Emmanuel
Macron est-ce que vous lui demandez de
parler à l'électorat de droite qui
s'apprête dimanche à voter pour lui
est-ce que vous lui demandez des
garanties par exemple sur le pacte
républicain nonon il y a pas de de
garantie à demander personne n'est en
mesure d'exiger des garanties des
conditions particulière non mais
Emmanuel Macron ce soir doit parler
aussi à votre électorat on va je vais
l'écouter ce soir comme je comme
beaucoup de de de français et je ferai
connaître dès demain mon engagement et
mon opinion pour avoir un engagement
responsable pour le second tour
d'élection présidentielle et il me
semble qu'effectivement on n'a pas trop
le choix nous dans notre famille
politique et que très
probablement sauf surprise ce soir
j'appellerai à voter pour pour le
candidat Macron très bien merci beaucoup
sans que c'était pour autant mon
candidat de cœur merci merci Philippe
nominetti d'avoir répondu à nos question
merci de rien au revoir voilà pour cet
entretien enregistré un peu plus tôt cet
après-midi il est 19h toujours en direct
sur public sa tout de suite le rappel
des titres face- à faceace attendu entre
les deux finalistes de la présidentielle
Marine Le Pen et Emmanuel Macron vont
débattre ce soir à la télévision temps
fort de cette campagne de l'entre de
Tours la confrontation est inédite mais
peut-elle encore faire bouger les lignes
et convaincre les abstentionnistes
l'analyse à suivre et ce débat opposera
deux visions de la société deux
programmes économiques irréconciliables
l'un basé sur le protectionnisme
économique et la défense d'une
souveraineté nationale l'autre sur la
mondialisation et l'Europe des thèmes au
cœur des discours des candidats ce soir
on en parle avec mes invités dans un
instant et à droite l'appel à vootter
Emmanuel Macron suscite encore des
remous vous venez de l'entendre certains
ténor estiment que voter pour le leader
d'en marche revient à affaiblir la
campagne des législatives elle sera
menée par françois Barouin le détail
dans cette édition et pour agir à cette
édition en direct sur Twitter le hashtag
présidentiel 360 je vous le disais c'est
un duel à haut risque cette joute
cathodi qui est aussi inédite
qu'attendue ce soir va pour la première
fois mettre au prise deux candidats non
issus des partis traditionnels alors
après de multiples tractation Marine Le
Pen et Emmanuel Macron ont accepté des
plans de coupe les derniers préparatifs
avec Eloise Grégoire le match de ce soir
s'annonce unique grande nouveauté de ce
débat de l'entre de tour les plans de
coupe sont enfin autorisé ce qui n'était
pas arrivé depuis
1974 enfin ils ont accepté les plans de
coupe avec modération c'est-à-dire que
le réalisateur pourra montrer la
personne qui ne parle pas comme ça en
plan d'écoute ce qui était interdit
depuis 81 depuis Moati et miteron c'est
une règle qu'ils avaient mis en place à
l'époque et qui permettait au candidats
de se se concentrer de relire ses notes
de boire un verre d'eau en 2012 avec la
même règle on aurait pu observer la
réaction de Nicolas SAR lors de ce
moment historique moi président de la
République je ne serai pas le chef de la
majorité je ne recevrai pas les
parlementaires de la majorité à l'Élysée
moi président de la République je ne
traiterai pas mon premier ministre de
collaborateur cette année une
scénographie très encadré avec pas moins
de 14 caméras pour couvrir ce face- à
faceace de 2h30 tout a été négocié en
amont le choix des Loges ou encore la
température du plateau à 19 degr autour
de cette tableovale Marine Le Pen sera à
gauche et commencera à parler et
Emmanuel Macron sera lui à droite et
aura le dernier mot à la présentation un
dio inédit exigé par la parité Nathalie
saint-cric de France 2 et Christophe
jacub bizine de TF1 aucun public sur le
plateau les candidats seront donc seuls
face à des millions de
téléspectateurs et ce débat promet
d'être une confrontation je le disais
entre deux visions opposées de la
société de programmes économiques à
l'opposé alors avant d'en parler avec
mes invités tour sur les propositions
des candidats avec Olivier
Cressé si un point oppose les programmes
des deux candidats à l'élection
présidentiell c'est bien celui-ci
l'Europe renforcement côté Macron
désengagement côté Le Pen la question
cristallise leur opposition fondamentale
l'euro tout d'abord le programme du
Front national offre sur ce point une
mesure radicale le rétablissement d'une
monnaie nationale cette mesure
s'accompagnerait de la possibilité pour
l'état de se financer directement auprès
de la Banque de France afin d'éviter la
pression des marchés financier et bien
moi je dis que il faut que nous ayons la
maîtrise de notre monnaie à noter que
depuis quelques jours Marine Le Pen a
quelque peu infléchi son discours en
évoquant la coexistence possible d'une
monnaie nationale et d'une monnaie
commune de son côté Emmanuel Macron ne
remet pas en cause les règles communes
en matière budgétaire il propose de
renforcer sa capacité d'action en dotant
la zone euro d'un budget commun qui
financerait des investissements et
servirait en cas de crise économique il
demande aussi un ministre des Finances
et un parlement de la zone euro la
volonté qui est la mienne c'est vraiment
d'aller plus loin sur justement cette
Europe plus intégrée sur ces
coopérations renforcées le libre échange
ensuite pour Marine Le Pen hostile aux
grands accords commerciaux comme le CTA
ou le tafta il s'agit de protéger les
frontières nationales en réinttroduisant
les droits de douane la candidate Front
national prône ce qu'elle appelle un
protectionnisme intelligent en évoquant
des marchés publics réservés aux
entreprises françaises le programme
d'Emmanuel Macron est beaucoup plus
favorable au libre échange le candidat
de la France en marche a toutefois
quelque peu infléchi discours lors de sa
dernière prise de parole sur le sujet du
CTA j'entends les
incertitudes ce que je déciderai sur ce
point c'est de nommer une commission
d'experts de scientifiques
irréprochables dé nuuer de tout lien
avec les lobby comme les industriels
pour dire ce qu'il en est exactement des
conséquences environnementales il
suggère également de créer un poste de
procureur commercial européen chargé du
contrôle de l'application des
engagements en matière sociale
environnementale et
fiscale et pour analyser les
propositions économiques des candidats
mes invités sur ce plateau ce soir
Christopher dambic bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes responsable de la
recherche économique chez saxobanque
j'accueille également Jean-Baptiste Dané
bonsoir vous êtes président de
croissance plus merci d'être avec nous
David Amiel est également sur ce plateau
bonsoir vous êtes conseiller économique
d'Emmanuel Macron et je précise pour les
télpect et bien que les soutiens de
Marine Le Pen que nous avions invité ont
finalement décliné notre invitation ils
sont partis et bien à l'assister pour le
débat télévisé de ce soir Christopher
damic première question on voit que
cette fin de campagne a été vraiment
marquée par et bien la question de la
mondialisation qui a cristalliser les
débats il en sera certainement question
ce soir lors du débat télévisé avec
whpool dressé comme symbole selon Marine
Le Pen des ravage d'une mondialisation
sauvage quelle est la seule je cite à
pouvoir donter est-ce que vous pensez
que et bien c'est vraiment le mal qui
ronge la France cette question de la
mondialisation aujourd'hui non très
clairement pas et surtout les solutions
qui sont apportées notamment le
protectionnisme il faut bien le rappeler
le protectionnisme par essence et
notamment celui qui est proposé par le
Front national mais qui était proposé
aussi par Donald Trump par exemple c'est
à la base un impôt un impôt qui va être
payé par le consommateur et des études
ont notamment été menées de manière très
intéressante aux États-Unis parmi ces
consommateurs lesquels vont être les
plus susceptible d'avoir une baisse du
pouvoir d'achat ce sont ceux qui sont
les plus défavorisés donc clairement le
protectionnisme aujourd'hui
n'est pas la bonne réponse notamment en
augmentant par exemple les taxes sur les
importations provenant de certains ta 3
% l'importation c'est la proposition de
Marine Le Pen mais elle parle d'un
protectionnisme intelligent on peut
faire du protectionnisme intelligent
selon vous Christopher on peut tout à
fait considérer qu'il y a certains
secteur d'activité stratégique ou par
exemple certains domaines dans les
start-ups qui doivent être plus protégés
de la concurrence étrangère on peut
aussi considérer en outre qu'il faut
avoir un pragmatisme en matière
commerciale c'est-à-dire lorsque la
Chine ne respecte pas les normes
commerciales la France peut tout à fait
faire de même avec l'aide de l'Union
européenne mais le gros problème c'est
qu'elle parle de protectionnisme
intelligent mais aucune de ces mesures
au niveau du protectionnisme ne reflète
cette idée-là on est sur un
protectionnisme qui excusez-moi rappelle
surtout les années 30 on essaie
soi-disant de protéger les emplois
français de la dé loocalisation ce qui
n'est pas la bonne solution avec ce
qu'elle propose ouais Jean-Baptiste Dané
ça peut être pourtant légitime de
vouloir défendre nos intérêts nationaux
dans cette mondialisation qui fait peur
he aux Français mais je je crois en fait
que il peut y avoir un protectionnisme
intelligent mais le le gros problème de
la façon dont Madame Le Pen et le Front
national l'expriment c'est que en fait
ils sont en train de supprimer des mots
du vocabulaire qui peuvent être des mots
qui sont viables pour les entrepreneurs
et les entreprises c'est dire que pour
nous il y a des formes de
protectionnisme et qui relève de
l'évidence mais qui n'ont rien à voir
avec le fait de couper de supprimer les
frontières enfin de de de rajouter les
frontières l'entrepreneur et
l'entreprise par essence accepte la
mondalisation elle peut éventuellement
le vivre de façon différente mais elle
l'accepte elle veut vivre avec et elle
veut se développer avec elle veut même
parfois anticiper les changements qui
sont en face de nous donc
protectionnisme intelligent avec quand
même de la régulation alors oui avec de
la régulation mais une régulation
raisonnable raisonnable en tout cas une
régulation qui ne va pas créer de
conflits irrémédable ou irréparable avec
nos voisins qui s'il faisait de même
nous mettrait dans une position plus que
délicate donc en fait il faut absolument
pas écouter ce genour de discours cette
petite musique à l'oreille sur le
protectionnisme qu'il est développé par
le Fond national est en fait un repli
sur soi et le et la cassure pour nos
entreprises ou David Amiel je rappelais
quand même que les Français justusent
très négativement cette mondialisation
avec cette désindustrialisation de la
France qui est là je pense qu'il faut
pour résumer finalement la manière dont
on doit aborder la mondialisation je
crois qu'il faut prendre la
mondialisation au sérieux donc la
prendre au sérieux c'est d'abord la
reconnaître comme ni bonne ni mauvaise
mais comme un fait historique mondial et
un fait historique majeur probablement
la plus grande transformation de notre
économie depuis 30 ans je donne un
chiffre il y a 50 ans 10 % de notre
richesse était produite grâce aux
exportations aujourd'hui c'est le triple
ça c'est la première chose mais la
prendre au sérieux ça veut aussi dire
bien sûr prendre au sérieux les
inquiétudes très souvent légitimes
qu'ell suscit et donc pour prendre ces
inquiétudes au sérieux il faut faire
deux chose il faut d'abord s'assurer que
dans cette mondialisation tout le monde
joue avec des règles
équitable donc on pourra revenir sur les
instruments qu'Emmanuel Macron souhaite
défendre au niveau européen pour s'en
assurer et la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
faut s'assurer que cette mondialisation
profite à tous c'est-à-dire que les
richesses qu'elle crée ne soi pas
réservé à quelques-uns mais qu'elle soi
partagé je dirais que les opportunités
soient partagées avec le plus grand
nombre de nos concitoyens c'est tout
l'enjeu Christopher demb il y a toujours
c'est laisser pour compte de la
mondialisation ces Français qui ont
l'impression justement d'en être plutôt
victimes que d'en bénéficier tout à fait
et puis il faut faire le différentielle
entre le centre sentiment des Français
qui est que la mondialisation a
finalement accentué les les inégalités
et la réalité des chiffres aujourd'hui
sur les 30 40 dernières années
finalement ce qu'on constate c'est que
la part de revenus total détenu par les
1 % les plus riches en France elle n'a
cessé de diminuer ce qui n'est pas le
cas par contre au Royaume-Uni ou aux
États-Unis donc globalement la
mondialisation finalement si on regarde
bien pour les Français en tout cas elle
a été globalement profitable ça ne on
n'empêche pas qu'il y a bien sûr eu des
laissés pour compte parce qu'on a eu un
phénomène de délocalisation
désindustrialisation qui est tout comme
la mondialisation un cycle inéluctable
du développement économique et donc
c'est surtout cet aspect là qu'il faut
prendre en compte d'où la nécessité
aujourd'hui d'avoir une vraie politique
de formation on a les moyens financiers
sont déjà sur la table mais la politique
de la formation est mal canalisée
finalement on sait que Marine Le Pen
veut taxer à hauteur de 35 % je Baptiste
d'année tout produit qui sortirait d'une
usine délocalisée pour être revendu sur
le marché français que pensez-vous de
cette proposition c'est c'est une
aberration c'est une aberration il y a
des exemples mais alors extrêmement
pragmatique vous avez des grandes
entreprises françaises qui fabriquent à
l'étranger ces grandes entreprises
françaises parfois fabriquent à
l'étranger des produits de grandes
nécessités ou en tout cas des produits
dont les Français ont besoin ou même ont
envie et que si ces produits revenaient
taxés ça reviendrait à pénaliser les
entreprise française si vous voulez le
vrai problème de ça c'est que la
mondialisation elle peut ou les risques
de la mondialisation ça peut être vécu
ou perçu on on accepte parfaitement les
deux la seule différence c'est que nous
chez croissance plus on considère que un
des critères c'est la répartition des la
répartition des fruits de la croissance
je crois que nous entreprise et on a pas
besoin du programme du Fond national
pour ça et on doit prendre n
responsabilités on doit dire maintenant
que l'entreprise est au cœur de la
problématique sociétale elle doit
prendre ses responsabilités et expliquer
aux salariés et aux collaborateurs que
ensemble nous allons démontrer que la
modalisation le train a déjà quitté le
qu et que nous sommes forcés de nous
adapter ouais David Amiel dans ce
contexte s'il y a effectivement cette
question européenne qui sera
certainement au centre du débat ce soir
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
élection présidentielle va se
transformer en référendum pour ou contre
l'Europe écoutez référendum pour ou
contre l'Europe je ne sais pas ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il y a une
opposition je dirais polaire entre le
projet d'Emmanuel Macron qui est un
projet qui s'appuie sur l'Europe comme
d'une arme pour défendre aussi les
intérêts de la France et les intérêts
des Français dans la mondialisation et
celui de Marine Le Pen que nous
considérons comme finalement une qute
capitulation c'estàdire de dire que nous
ne pouvons pas utiliser le levier
européen pour peser je pense qu'il faut
être très clair là-dessus euh nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un monde de
grande puissance nous avons la Chine qui
euh utilise sans vergogne ses armes
commerciales contre nous Emmanuel Macron
s'est mobilisé au niveau européen pour
lutter contre c'était l'affaire du
dumping sur l'acier chinois entre
décembre 2015 et décembre 2016 grâce aux
mesures qui ont été prises les euh
importations d'acier en provenance de
Chine ont été divisées par 200 donc nous
avons un levier au niveau européen pour
s'assurer que les règles du monde de
demain les règles de la mondialisation
ne sont pas écrites ni à Pékin ni à
Washington mais prennent en compte les
intérêts des Européens c'est la première
chose ensuite il y a une deuxième chose
c'est qu'il faut s'assurer non seulement
que l'Europe fait respecter ses
préférences dans la mondialisation il
faut aussi s'assurer qu'au sein de
l'Europe tous jouent finalement par les
mêmes règles donc on est également très
clair là-dessus on pourra revenir sur
chacun des dossiers la première chose
c'est que il est intolérable qu'il y ait
des notamment de la directive
travailleurs détachés c'est pour cela
qu'il faut la réviser donc Emmanuel
Macron soutient cette révision la
deuxème
ch suppression de cette directive
travailleurs détachés du côté de Marine
Le Pen non écoutez la suppression de la
directive travailleurs détachés ce
serait mettre en péril les centaines de
milliers de travailleurs détachés
français que nous avons à travers
l'Europe il ne s'agit pas de la
supprimer il s'agit de s'assurer que à
travail égal on est un salaire égal dans
toute finalement la chaîne du travail
détaché il s'agit aussi de s'assurer
qu'il n'y a pas d'utilisation du travail
détaché pour des tâches qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être c'est pour ça que nous
proposons de réduire la durée possible
du détachement de 2 ans à 1 an et la
troisième chose c'est de permettre une
lutte beaucoup plus forte contre la
fraude et c'est également un sujet qui
devrait être abordé par donc dans la
révision de la directive ouais sur ce
point des travailleurs détachés
suppression de la directive ou
redéfinition des règles du jeu christop
non très clairement redéfinition des
règles du jeu et surtout il faut
souligner qu'il y a un point qui est
extrêmement important effectivement on a
un taux de chômage qui est très élevé en
France mais le fait est que lorsqu'on
regarde notamment pour les organisations
patronnales aujourd'hui dans les emplois
industriels vous avez un/ers de main
d'œuvre qui manque d'après les
entreprises dans le secteur industriel
donc indénéablement ce qu'il faut bien
vous comprendre c'est qu'on a besoin
aussi dans certains secteurs d'activité
d'immigration de main d'œuvre étrangère
qui va permettre le développement
économique tout simplement pour deux
raisons soit parce qu'en France si on
veut former ces personnesl ça va prendre
beaucoup trop de temps soit tout
simplement parce que pour certains
emplois il faut être très franc les
Français ne veulent pas les assurer
parce qu'ils sont mal rémunérés parce
qu'ils sont douloureux ou et cetera donc
dans tous les cas je crois que mettre en
avant cette directive des travailleurs
détaché je voyage très souvent en
Pologne et c'est un gros sujet là-bas
justement c'est un peu
brandir un problème qui n'en est
réellement pas un parce que concrètement
on a un problème de main d'œuvre en
France aujourd'hui notamment sur
certains emplois industriels ouais sur
ce point vous êtes d'accord avec ce
notre dit alors parfaitement je crois
que ce Bou émissaire qui est brandi en
ce moment sur l'Europe je pense que
c'est pas vraiment le sujet je crois que
la question à regarder elle est
essentiellement également chez nous nous
nous sommes 400 400 entreprises on sait
tous même si c'est un sujet
dialectiquement extrêmement complexe à
manier parce qu'on connaît le le
le les les problèmes les problèmes du
chômage et même les les problèmes
sociétaux que que ça pose il n'empêche
que c'est vrai que nous cherchons à
recruter euh parfois de façon très
importante des gens nous ne trouvons pas
des gens qui répondent pas deuxième
chose il faut pas confondre le problème
de l'Europe et le problème effectivement
de la de la concurrence entre pays
européen qu'elle soit mieux géré ça
c'est ça fait partie du du programme
d'Emmanuel Macron bien sûr mais surtout
de dire que ça fait partie de notre de
nos erreurs fiscales des 10 dernières
années à un moment regardons en France
le coup du travail le coût pour les
entreprises la liberté d'embaucher la
liberté revoir le code du travail et
permettre estce que vous faites
confiance à Emmanuel Macron qui a été
ministre de l'Économie justement et bien
pour apporter les solution que vous
attendez alors faire confiance je je
crois que c'est c'est pardonnez-moi mais
je crois pas que c'est comme ça que
jeaais répondre à votre question si
aujourd'hui vous me dites est-ce que
dans les deux candidats qui rest c'est
lui que vous avec lequel vous envie de
travailler la réponse est clairement oui
je me suis exprimé sur le sujet nous
nous sommes exprimés sur le sujet
deuxièmement force de constater que sur
les deux dernières années dans un
gouvernement qui lui était à priori
hostile Emmanuel Macron est le seul qui
a eu le courage d'avoir et de faire de
mener des réformes d'envergure elles
sont pas toutes allé au bout mais sont
des réformes d'envergure qui allaient
dans le sens de l'entreprise
troisièmement nous considérons
qu'Emmanuel Macron connaî l'entreprise
connaî les entrepreneurs j'ai eu
l'occasion de le rencontrer une ou deux
fois sur deux ou trois sujets à berc à
l'époque il m'a semblé que c quelqu'un
qui comprenait parfaitement nos
problématiques la façon dont il a
travaillé sur la Rép i des fruits de la
croissance avec le système des actions
gratuites nous convenait plutôt bien et
ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui dans son
programme aujourd'hui même si nous
allons nous s'il est élu dialoguer avec
lui avec fermeté parce que nous sommes
des entrepreneurs et qu'il faut toujours
repartir au combat a priori nous trouons
nous trouvons qu'il y a des très bonnes
choses dans ce programme oui David Amiel
c'est pas aussi contreproductif pour
Emmanuel Macron qui peut apparaître
comme le candidat et bien qui bénéficie
aussi du soutien des entreprises du
patronat c'est justement sur ce point
peut-être que Marine Le Pen veut
l'attaquer ce soir contre elle qui
serait la candidate du peuple non
écoutez pardon de rappeler un peu des
évidences enfin je pense que tout le
monde sait qu'en France ce sont d'abord
les entreprises qui créent de l'emploi
et qui créent de la richesse donc je
pense qu'être soutenu par par des des
gens qui sont précisément confrontés à
toutes ces difficultés de la
mondialisation qui sont souvent les
premiers à se battre précisément contre
leurs concurrents étrangers pour
conquérir des marchés pour créer de
l'activité non je crois qu'au contraire
c'est un très bon signal et qu'on voit
que au contraire face au programme de
Marine Le Pen se dressent pas les entre
prise du C 40 pas les banques pas les
assurances puisquen plus visiblement eux
bénéficieraient d'une monnaie qui
resterait stable et sûre mais on voit
bien l'inquiétude de tous les patrons de
PME de tous les patrons de petites
entreprises qui voit bien ce que son
programme protectionniste ce que son
programme de destruction monétaire en
Couret de risque pour eux et les emplois
qu'il créent même s'il y a aussi un vote
Front national chez de nombreux artisans
ça ça a été vu notamment lors de cette
campagne davidiel mais mais mais c'est
pour ça que je demand des mesures de
protection prendre en compte les
inquiétudes légitimes on a parlé de la
directive travailleurs détachés on
pourlera parler également du niveau des
charges qui font aussi peser lourdement
sur nos artisans nos commerçants tous
ceux qui sont en première ligne de la
concurrence internationale un fardau
parfois excessif c'est pour ça que nous
baissons considérablement les charges de
l'ordre de 1800 € par an au niveau du
SMIC c'est pour ça que nous réduisons
les impôt c'est pour ça aussi que nous
nous battrons au niveau européen pour
une harmonisation sociale et fiscale qui
est effectivement indispensable
Christopher DAMB il y a deux mesures
aussi qui s'opposent c'est elle concerne
pour Marine Le Pen les appels d'offrees
publiqu seraient réservé en priorité aux
entreprises françaises de son côté
Emmanuel Macron propose et bien un BA
européan Act qui réserve l'accès au
marchés publics aux entreprises qui
localise au moins la moitié de leur
production en Europe si on fait le match
de ces deux mesures vous avez deux
visions qui sont complètement
différentes c'est veà dire une vision
européenne et qui est forcé de le
constater réaliste c'estàd on peut être
tout à fait critique de l'Union
européenne de son fonctionnement on va
très certainement pas suffisamment loin
il y a des problèmes financiers par
exemple aujourd'hui on voit des fuites
de capitaux de l'Italie vers l'Allemagne
mais fondamentalement aujourd'hui la
réalité que c'est par l'Europe que la
France trouvera son salut parce que tout
simplement c'est aussi un marché
extrêmement important pour nos
entreprises européennes pour nos
entreprises françaises on oublie très
souvent aussi que de très nombreuses PME
de grandes entreprises exportent
arrivent à travailler dans les pays
d'Europe notamment en Europe de l'Est
donc on va vers des vases communicquants
faut pas croire qu'il y a juste le
phénomène de délocalisation du côté de
Marine Le Pen elle reprend un peu des
thématiques existe dans d'autres pays
mais je pense effectivement qu'il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin il faut avoir
une vision aujourd'hui européenne parce
que la France seule ne pourra pas
réussir sachant qu'elle ne réussit pas
aussi bien que cela déjà avec l'Union
européenne alors on parlait de la sortie
de l'euro et du rétablissement d'une
monnaie nationale sur cette mesure phare
et bien que Marine Le Pen conditionne 70
% de son programme économique écoutez ce
qu'on disait Bernard monau député
européen et qui a participé au programme
économique de la candidate frontiste
l'idée générale c'est de négocier en
moyenne 6 mois avec les institutions et
nos partenaires de le regroupe alors
après à quelques mois près c'est pas
c'est pas le sujet pour arriver donc à
euh des résultats de ces renégociations
d'appartenance de la France à l'Union
européenne et à la zone euro et au
regard de ces de de ces résultats Marine
Le Pen fera choisir les Français en
fonction du résultat de ces
renégociations avec par référendum donc
bien entendu les Français seront
associés à l'évolution nous allons
parallèlement avoir un grand débat sur
ce sujet de la monnaie qui est un
véritable carcan et ça peut prendre à
quelques mois après voilà le temps des
négociations et ensuite la mise en place
une fois que tous nos partenaires auront
été convaincus du bien faait et bien
après ce sera le temps nécessaire pour
le mettre en œuvre mais de toute façon
tout ce ça se fera dans le consensus et
la tranquillité l'objectif de Marine Le
Pen et la stabilité financière
économique monétaire et bancaire aussi
car tout le système bancaire européen
aujourd'hui est en état d'urgence en
Italie en Allemagne Jean-Baptiste Dané
on vient d'entendre Bernard mono sur
justement cette évolution du discours du
Front national sur une sortie de l'euro
et un retour à la monnaie nationale
est-ce que vous êtes rassuré par ce que
vous venez d'entendre je suis pas du
tout rassuré mais enfin je l'étais pas
avant je le suis pas plus maintenant
même si alors là je m'exprime à titre
personnel je vois bien que il y a des
ajustements qui sont en train d'être
fait mais qui sont justement politici
une consultation un référendum he les
Français ne sont pas pas forcmentevenir
àour d'autant plus que croissante plus
c'est par définition une association
entrepreneuse d'entrepreneurs àoltique
donc le notre sujet c'est l'économie et
le parti de l'entreprise cependant il y
a quand même quelque chose qui est
extrêmement gênant dans ce qui est dit
c'est cette
naïveté de faire croire que la
négociation avec l'Europe sur la sortie
de la France de l'euro peut se passer de
manière paisible c'est absurde ça
n'existe pas premièrement deuxièmement
est-ce que vous croyez qu'on a le temps
d'attendre les atermoim
d'un parti au pouvoir qui commencera à
négocier contre l'Europe contre l'Europe
c'estd déstabiliser l'ensemble de
l'Europe monétaire fiscale financière
est-ce que vous pensez que les
entreprises entrepreneurs ont le temps
d'attendre troisièmement alors là
absurdité majeur en plus à la fin quand
tout le monde sera brouillé autour de la
table parce qu'il n'en sera pas
autrement ensuite on va demander la vie
du peuple français mais non c'est pas ça
gouverner gouverner c'est assurer de la
stabilité prendre des engagement assurer
de la stabilité l'inverse de ce qui est
proposé là donc nous sommes
fondamentalement compte d'ailleurs c'est
le préalable préalable au fait que nous
soyons contre ouais David Amiel il y a
une évolution je le disais du discours
du frond national sur cette sortie de
l'euro qui serait davantage négocié
soumise à référendum écoutez je
commenterai pas les évolutions c'est
asse dramatique de voir qu'on avait une
monnaie avant le premier tour qu'on
avait deux monnaies dans l'entre de
Tours j'ai envie de dire s'il y avait eu
un trisème tour auraiton eu trois
monnaies en fait on ne sait plus
vraiment où est le Front national on
voit bien qu'il maîtrise extrêmement mal
ces sujets ce ne serait pas très grave
ça ne faisait pas posé une lourde menace
sur l'économie française tout ce qui a
dit Monsieur Menot est faux c'est-à-dire
que le jour même où Marine Le Pen serait
élu présidente de la République vous
aurez immédiatement une attaque sur
l'ensemble de la dette française sur
l'ensemble de l'argent français ce n'est
pas un projet peur que nous agiterions
en 20 on a eu un exemple on a eu
l'exemple grec où précisément quand la
sortie de l'euro a commencé à être
discuté immédiatement le gouvernement
grec a dû fermer les banques limiter à
60 € par jour les retraits possibles ce
serait ex le type de mesure qu'un
gouvernement Front national serait amené
à prendre ou 30 secondes pour conclure
sur ce point Christopher dambic très
clairement on peut souhaiter la sortie
de la zone euro mais évidemment on ne
peut pas dire que ce sera un dollur au
citoyens il faut être très franc ce sera
dramatique économiquement et bien merci
pour votre analyse Christopher dembiic
Jean-Baptiste Dané et David Amiel c'est
la fin de cette édition spéciale tout de
suite on continue sur les chaînes
parlementaires à vous faire vivre et
bien l'avant débat télévisé on retrouve
d'ailleurs et bien AR et Michel zames
pour le bfort suivi du débat à 21h et du
débrief animé par Sonia mabrou très
bonne soirée à tous sur les chaînes
[Musique]
parlementaire